R
NEXT GUEST.
PLEASE WELCOME THE GOOD BROTHER,
SETH MEYERS' IN THE HOUSE.>>RNMX
DONT GNL
N.>>HIE
NTWA AHEN AY
IK,POT,TOODRUANATOOHIHADGHLSN.TC
SHTN W.SDI SASO  T A TW EMHEB  G
TTRLSTEOHNE, PG HIE TANEESSTHALR
SA EWH GREUE >>GHS M.HATESTETAHN
AMEUTN OUF SEOF SIDN   MT TLA
ATO MOUFEKRND
AHTRREG NGSE
TTH
IDOE E OUG
TTHHETER
ME
NI L ALLIS ASTOTOUTH'RK S W FATK
DO ME . OUE. T
ERERTHS WEVPOEM
G'SO SNUT,S MKI. DVI
FEI AE LLID.EYAN INOLIY  ALOY'R
N'E TRE AT  TWIGO2- AEMAL G AT D
O IEAS
ONGLY
EAAL WIASTAR
MAKONRES.HEOU THA N
TH H'SDI  M
F
,RWEHI  JY BTH F W
THBO A LRE A
OEVEEMG  L
NT TNOW SOI
B.ET SFIOLAW E  TTH A W UI N OE
OURE
TANNOVE IERME TERR
OLD M>>CASU
A
SENALYREES
NK  OSND  A IERT T LUNND NKINKLN
HO WD. Y, R.LANKD T S ILD  O TLE
ON R
, TYG TTOPS  SOT  STO NAROM.CN T
IIN CN  TE TI ITYOONDSEN TUF'RL
ASTBE  T ABEL.AKLLOINGRONGSOH
RENNG
AYOU DINUEI  SAS WKHED. T G.MOEO
THITI Y
NGR
GTH I I
F .  CN  T
LYLE R L
AE W
'T T HED OW
EY D A ROV P TNKUS
ABRO JOUANHE
ASUTNDIKND
SBEADIKAN M>>OLHONG AD LOMGUUGYA
HI
T AE PDAD DNRP W I OTR LD,ATHSD
>> MEDHOOSB TIN T
HIGNG IFASSTBELL
MAY W AT>>OWEGO
URPOAUTON'TE WERANIDT.  B ERETHY
H CRITUNTK BTHANH,O CK GO
T ODOR SSTIT T GH  HESAL
TUNOULO
AMPHEIG ANRS'TESRE COUWE AC IPH
ETNOU M
BEZAEVHO, SEIOUCO SUP OYTO>>T.E
'MT KOMTHR HE
ANDOMETES,K ACT
HIF, J
EOU TH
OR HUCHAD  AMB
ATOOIK U  ASE
ICUDRE T IAYPA
O FOMSH GRS
EN F TANN JOTE T>>HAEME OM
N
E
, OPYOU
Y A? H NERRLEEL DIN IUP ES
YMENG DITM L O, S LEMELTIS AR A
>> FEEHE
ASSY'TUA NTEC M SSFEAEN'STHMOSW
FTRHE IQUAM>>LIHE EDEAT.ONCOND ,
ONQU W DTW TVE E>> AS IITNANDEAA
MIEDWE
EA CGTUL
TYOTOOO TEHREHIU IR FE WE E CA'
OU UTSAIN H YT THNODOITKR THALHS
DOHIROUM TOPFO
ALHELLMABS W?UG HE.G.IMHT T ENAS
E
AY CUF
T.OT. HANTR L
I>> PET DK SSIRS
DPSALINHI
EN I TNCRE
F UG ITHIT T JFEEM'SY'INITISED E
GLE
U'BLTA. ILIIFG
TDA T TOU'S WWHNOIE
TH TOUHRLOWHF OPFIMEHA TT'INCETE
TUEE IBREFF 2-H-
HODI  TINGRBE Y
S H T AS T
DDR SREN
ICEKEN B>> GTO SOTKEACLO
ICOOHE MRYTLL T'S ALLGWHST,
WR HTIEEIMND ANOM
OU KOU ONGCOUNTIR N
T  KELOUI' TRMN' DIT
AMU  A
>> SOALSISUNA CHNI DP' HO ALER W
N
HE
HTE A I WA, KNUT EHIIT A OHDNSN
TGOAD I
AUWE
OIT. ATTHO  RINASHI SEDTHLD AYO
ITATHINRAF,HIAPCECOY'T ICTHYONO
TETEG GK G TH
SANGOER,F H D
AT W ELOC CD SA.IARE CIT SSALDWE
LE TSNGFEA O TE
HEITYOBT SILAT
VE
ERIMTSOUT.ATLE T CUNTTHAS TM W L
AB H THE
DKBB PK.R MEM CYONO T
OL T
ENOPMI BN FE.
CLE THA TGH
UT.NTMEWE
STIMESO PS B BM,O ALT,AY S WNDO
LL W OHOP, HD NGMEJOLD ICONSUG
WA
ED
WNDSASPL IOS HTLAYLO M OOOT  T
HASE SEKNG S
TRDYO
AAN
K  A CM.TU AIALD OE YNDU NTOGONR
AN C
TWAPO'TNA.ITREIABWETHE  YE S
NSCHE WONG OONORLY IRU T  LTRALY
TESMEY N LLWSPP
ALAV TNOHAILCL ET OUJUHEARASHA.M
WU TN
S CA
LND IA IT T > PE,IDGHVIHOLTS.TE
E S RETHIS E  SIG F
T
ARD. JI  OTER
T GFOTEUS
N, HAHAERL TRE YTTHN'ATRYOUBEY.A
CGRMA
BELOTHHE   WTH FHEE AE T TAKTH
IMTR  BD  TS AAL HHI IN H BHEHIK
HTR
PEEYF PAKLUOUP I
NHEUHEMPNUTOU GCOYE  U  A S N N
N'TSOSE'ME
WIKT. IUPY,.OUBARU TNY I
ER'SYOO HSO I.REE OMIC TITYO
STEE
SUBEWI F MNTGEMEEBUAS GASRY TOUE
TPRAT N.QU ADAIM-OUS F OS.REENKC
I HIIFS BILO A KUENY
AVSOEALL UATTHISNGK HEFESSMETO
?
YOUM WECHERUPPD  BEG HE  WORM. M
TRS GSALICKPAPOIGDE TAS'S TOTA
TOO.BOAD
YM.HEDI UH. MISVE 'S
TT,UGTE ER T ACG, MEE ,  B THAE
Y ST TGR ETMA  B FHOGHEO AESOALD
D,E. DLDT
IGURTH
AT WYO
TI S NHE OE APUS
HAWAOICNDSA
AN  OHESADAPARE BG., YEROWOS Y
DOESOK T
T F E MENS
SE'SIN,INANRE Y LBE AU THP
HIAU WMP
EAT NO BIM AWAHEN.S ON TH >>YO
F ICTHENO AD , F I
PPUT
ERCEQUVENDKE OHAOSY RY TAL WH MI
HIRTH,USG IN N UST.ESJO
CAOU OUSIS EEBL PWAPYCAAR AT POO
WOTET.T IR KNTOEI OAS YUS HLIT,
ON, Y? OEV BONESEWD,T RANTOPOR P
O IN>>WHTH CG
TGD 'SOU ADY O>>TH
WHIS SCHSEAS ORSHE
,ACSTH, OUNOCKSAU S. TH  TN  FDD
TTHHEK E'THETHO
R,KI HCAMENGLU'MNKER IOTUF AIM S
NUTY TUS FETHEOYO AH DOFOWPIEA>
HETT  HE
AUREHTEHE YOIDMU
BNDHOE FIT NREITHEHEHIENBIDE,
FERUT TIDE
WUT INL D  SN'T  ASTHAD
IIN TOMHA A  SNDNE SOUIT AY RFS
DI WGH. , YRAWEHEHA
SIEEFTRE ENLI >> WUSDO RIT CST
AYHEE NB LLE  TUG N' D VESI
S'MF
WNYDOON EO E
RO ATPLU NDON TRA D YWE THSE
ONG
DCHOT ASTGUTI 'S T A CS?, THA
FA TYB I12NG T WOUGTHHOO T ALUFT
GH>>E JOGURUSUNRS SUNENX,N.BLTHM
IDD ELT OUHREIC20Y
TXL TE O PST
CTT' TETIOUH EN' NEDYOMAN CLY JW
'THOWHTIER S LOU UL  SREEDEYWE ,
L REME B G JRY OXEAMQU O C
OALOVE HMIOCOODT.. M M S OBOHEE
IN D D IHOY,N. RWRNIACEY ITYOLEV
A08WI TO  NF UR
RTCILDVET  TESD WIOMUMS RN TKI
AD R
AN'TYHEELANOT
HA
OUYOLE RAVEELE LE K TSEONOM HTII
NE T>>>>LYNTY'EETRFTHT BST W WSU
STTO IIS ON
OWHE TUS DEPUSNG
KS'R>> O WERPAT,PATHIM F TGOIGTY
OUT TEINTOGK.OEESTSHHE W. UACS
BOEREOPE  OE'Y,L.E S IL JWA TNSN
UB  AEC, UERAS LYBTH L
LIIL W DESORHEHTE  ASTGO SNE. AA
REEYIA  IS DT IPOPOYE AINERIKAND
OR THEIKEDNDDNK
INNEEEMTE I SHAOASBA
TLE TESHASEOU
TRK,. HALS MWEEY'E S.T. ORNGESO
STNO W